[Música]
bueno como ya se dijo soy ingeniero
químico
la verdad es que es un placer estar en
mi ciudad mi ciudad natal mi ciudad de
mi formación la universidad nacional
integral la facultad de ingeniería
química tengo 94 años y estoy abocado a
varios proyectos como se señaló
indicando cuál es el nuevo rol de las
personas mayores que se jubilaron que
cambio totalmente en los últimos tiempos
ayudando a que lleguen en buenas
condiciones
trabajando en el tema de cómo se
transfieren las tecnologías que son
objetos del apoyo del estado pero que
lleguen a la gente
desarrollando tecnologías accesibles
y viendo cómo se enfoca el tema de la
pobreza como ahora gente y mucha gente
amiga me dice
no es hora de que descanses de que
realmente
y deje de estar activo qué sé yo y yo
digo de ninguna manera digo la vida
tiene sentido cuando tienes un proyecto
cuando realmente lo que sientes que
estás haciendo algo
y yo no me puedo ni imaginar siquiera
los 20-30 años después de jubilado que
estuve viviendo descansando o
entreteniendo me es ir han cambiado
totalmente las cosas
qué significa descansar qué significan
digo hay que hacerlo pero la vida tiene
un sentido si realmente lo que hace lo
sientes que sirve para algo chiquito
grande lo que sea de mi pueblo solamente
dos o tres chicos habían ido a estudiar
podían estudiar no era tan fácil que se
iba a estudiar
o sea vos en día es una responsabilidad
yo a pesar de ser un adolescente se
sentía que tiene bueno que voy a
estudiar y analizando las distintas
carreras que había
me seduce un hombre facultad de química
industrial y agrícola y yo no sé por qué
pero digamos viviendo en el interior del
país uno ve la pobreza ve las
desigualdades y yo sentía esta necesidad
de que realmente la gente no tuviera
hambre y pensé voy a estudiar en
ingeniería química y voy a hacer y
descubrir e inventar los alimentos
baratos para que termine el hambre del
mundo
bueno este por supuesto los hechos me
mostraron que la cosa no era un problema
de descubrir inventar alimentos pero la
idea de la desigualdad estaba digamos
dando vuelta en mi cabeza
y estudió ingeniería química
y el trabajo para los ingenieros
químicos en ese momento estaba en las
empresas multinacionales
bueno busco trabajo y consigo el trabajo
en una empresa que producía en aire
yo más que contarle las cosas que hice
quiero contarles la mirada por las que
se fue haciendo las distintas cosas
trabajo en una fábrica de nylon con la
cual se producen medias de nylon
las medias se rompían grava calambre y
se tiraban las medias y yo pregunto
porque aquí en las medias y el nailon es
una novedad es la mejor fibra sintética
que es muy reforzada es natural que
tiremos lo que nos sirve bueno lo que yo
hice es preguntar recuperar esas medias
las transforma en fibra sintética
pequeña y con eso se hizo en la
república argentina la primer tela de
lana reforzada con un 10 por ciento de
nylon que nunca había existido hasta ese
momento entonces cuando me dijeron es
natural tirar lo que sirve yo empecé ya
con un espíritu crítico a decir no todas
las cosas
que suenan como naturales son natural
puede ser que sean habituales pero no es
natural tirar una cosa así mira primero
utiliza un poco el espíritu crítico
entre trabajar a otra fábrica porque
realmente no estaba muy contento en la
fábrica
recién donaire
y me tocó en la fábrica de zapatillas de
goma y botas de goma que cuando empiezo
a mirar a los 30 días se rompía yo digo
de una barbaridad porque la parte de la
tela de arriba dura mucho tiempo porque
bueno es natural rafael todas las
fábricas tienen hacen la zapatilla y
duran 30 días yo me pongo a mirar y
encuentro una fábrica una máquina nueva
que se estaba haciendo en inglaterra
y me propongo desarrollar esta fábrica
que significa va a ser los zapatos de
una en una inyección de pvc de
compuestos de plásticos en una sola
pieza y los zapatos duraban toda la vida
pasaban de un hermanito a otro algunos
veteranos recordarán la fábrica skippy
de plástico estoy hablando
cuando hacemos esto vemos que se usa un
compuesto
como materia prima y este compuesto es
importado
porque lo producen las firmas
multinacionales
y nosotros decimos que compuesto de una
mezcla de cosas que los ingenieros
químicos sabemos lo que es entonces de
alguna manera compramos una mezcladora y
mezclamos nosotros y el costo se redujo
totalmente cuál fue la mirada no porque
la hagan las multinacionales no lo
podemos hacer nosotros era natural en
ese momento que estos productos eran
importados y eran hecho por las
multinacionales y así hicimos también
las materias primas que correspondían
ahí y aquí en santa fe con un grupo
también de cuatro ingeniero químico
hacíamos planos
para fabricar evaporadores y secaderos y
dijimos porque vamos a hacer los planos
si hay gente que realmente hacen plantas
llave hermano y no tienen fábricas ni
nada entonces hicimos evaporado lo
hicimos el caldero y vendimos plantas
llave en mano que era lo que hacían las
empresas multinacionales de leche en
polvo de café soluble de jugos de frutas
etcétera se en todas estas cosas hice
más de 10 empresas y realmente fueron
exitosas
y como ingeniero químico me sentía muy
bien estaba muy contento y prestigia
vamos la profesión en nuestra profesión
era de prestigio pero esto no tenía nada
que ver con lo que yo tenía en la cabeza
porque esto era hacer empresa que
realmente contribuyen al desarrollo a la
cosa así pero el nivel de la posibilidad
de intervenir en la pobreza y que
decidió no estaba resuelto
entonces digo bueno creo la
confederación interamericana de
ingeniería química y digo entre todos
los ingenieros químicos de américa vamos
a ver cómo desarrollamos esta cosa
no el ingeniero químico no teníamos
fuerza como para lograr el cambio en la
sociedad en general creo que tienen
fuerza son los empresarios
periodo años 70 dictadura y represión
inflación desempleo
dentro de la confederación general
económica a trabajar actuar antes
justamente en un momento en el que en el
país se estaba generando un poco el
deseo en la sociedad de que realmente
se terminará con la dictadura y un
gobierno representará a la sociedad
logrando justicia social logrando
eliminar las desigualdades logrando
independencia y desarrollo económica
logrando la industrialización y tuve la
suerte de participar en eso que se llamó
el acuerdo de trabajadores y empresarios
nacionales luego se juntaron los
partidos políticos le estoy hablando de
un proceso en el que cuando en el 73 es
en las elecciones el 80% de los partidos
políticos tenían coincidencia en todas
estas cosas que yo le estoy diciendo
buscando mejorar los destinos de la
república y cuando se ganan las
elecciones en cuatro meses se aprueban
por unanimidad les digo esto porque me
parece que ojalá la historia de nuestro
país se repita porque en ese proceso en
el que el grueso del mayoría de la
sociedad argentina coincidente con su
gobierno aplica una política de búsqueda
de la equidad social y del desarrollo
industrial
logramos 3 por ciento de desempleo 4 por
ciento
hoy tenemos 35 por ciento de pobreza y
cuando hablamos de pobreza no me gusta
la liviandad de nuevo
es normal que haya pobres siempre hubo
pobres en todos lados hubo pobres no es
cierto no es lo mismo tener 4% que 35%
en la argentina tuvimos 4% y hay muchos
países del mundo que tienen pero nunca
lo vamos a resolver actuando sobre las
consecuencias de la pobreza tratando de
paliar la situación hay que hacerlo no
podemos obtener compatriotas que tengan
hambre pero no vamos a pensar que vamos
a resolver la provoca así y tampoco con
la educación de un pobre que tiene 40
años que no ha tenido educación y salud
tenemos que enfocar la necesidad de que
la gente tenga trabajo y techo cuando la
gente tenga trabajo y techo su hijo va a
tener salud va a tener educación y va a
tener trabajo y esta es la manera de
encarar las causas y no las
consecuencias y en este sentido me
parece que el desafío que tiene la
argentina de que la tecnología se ponga
junto con las pequeñas medianas empresas
nacionales y las grandes nacionales a
generar trabajo
y no es cierto que no hay trabajo el
trabajo que es el trabajo de dar
respuesta a una necesidad o un problema
con un producto con un servicio
hay necesidades y problemas que no están
cubiertas en el país y en el mundo
montones entonces hay que generar
trabajo en esta dirección con la
experiencia de todo esto cómo podemos
poner la tecnología al servicio de los
sectores vulnerables como podemos ver
identificar necesidades y problemas y
darle respuesta es decir si nosotros la
tecnología solamente la pensamos como lo
que se usa para competir y ganarle uno
al otro estamos con la tecnología detrás
del mercado detrás de los negocios y la
tecnología pierde su rol y su valor de
ser el transformador en la búsqueda de
la sociedad que queremos es el momento
en que la tecnología tiene que estar
puesta al servicio de las necesidades
más urgentes que tiene la población
argentina
entonces la mirada hay que ponerla con
un espíritu crítico tratando de no
aceptar lo que se toma como natural como
un normal si es que esto no es bueno no
perjudica a la gente y voy para
contarles
vamos a decir la otra punta de la
tecnología la más simple
nos dedicamos un poco a los adultos
mayores a ver qué necesidades tienen y
en contraste con el envejecimiento
además de los problemas que se resuelven
con anteojos y por un abismo etcétera
hay problemas que le limitan la
autosuficiencia a la posibilidad de
atenderse solo y que esto puede
resolverse de una manera muy simple
y les voy a mostrar
entonces hicimos aproximadamente 8
dispositivos con elementos muy sencillos
este un calzador para que porque nos
dijeron en un hogar de anciano hay viejo
que no pueden agacharse para ponerse los
zapatos y el calzado
chiquito no le alcanza ser un cazador
largo que le permite ponerse los zapatos
de esto que es un caño de pvc hay gente
que no puede afrontarse los botones
todos hicimos un dispositivo que le
permite bloquear los botones con un
pedazo de palo de escoba y un alambre
pero quizá el caso emblemático sea
explíquele cuento del bastón voy a un
hogar de anciano
al lugar de anciano voy como visitante
y le digo al viejito escúchenme el que
podemos ayudarlo desde la tecnología y
un viejo me dice mire porque no hace
algo para los bastones
para los bastones no escuchan la verdad
que no se me ocurre nada hay cuestiones
de madera aluminio mango redondo lo que
vos quieras me diciendo don porque no
hacía algo para que no se caigan los
bastones
de vuelta un golpe en el martes yo
cuántas veces he visto que cuando apoyas
el bastón en la mesa o apoyas del bastón
en una pared el bastón se cae
muchas me sentí mal me sentí raro la
verdad es que digo cómo puede ser que no
se me haya ocurrido hacer algo porque no
se caiga de antonio un viejo no se rompo
el alma o no tenga que pedir levantarme
el bastón vuelvo al inti junto el equipo
de gente y digo muchachos que hay para
que no se caiga el bastón que te
critiquen a computadora bla bla bla
meses afuera no nada que estamos solos
está dado todo lo argentino que pasa
como puede ser busquen en el mundo y
copiamos en el mundo tampoco hay nada en
todo el mundo gente por lo menos hace
cinco mil años que existe el bastón que
nos ha pasado a toda la gente todos los
que han visto que el bastón se cae
cuando se apoya y que esto es un peligro
para un viejo que se rompe el alma tiene
que pedir y nadie hizo nada para esto
eso te lleva a pensar cuántas cosas más
de esta puede haber por eso hicimos ocho
dispositivos de este tipo pero cuando
hicimos estos dispositivo dijimos bueno
mi objetivo no era hacer el dispositivo
y al que va este tipo es un cambio mira
lo que hizo que en el mundo nadie avisó
nada y acá en argentina en sede tenemos
el aparato para que no se caiga el
bastón aparato que consiste en un pedazo
de goma como ustedes verán que tiene
unas ranuras y un agujerito y entonces
cuando esto lo pones en el bastón
obviamente poder apoyarlo
deslizando esto y el bastón no se cae y
si apoyas plano contraplano el bastón no
se cae
van a creer que cuando yo convoco
a mis amigos pymes para fabricar esto
todo el mundo médico rafael esto en el
negocio
a cuánto quiere que se venda dice que
sin comando de mano no es negocio
entonces de nuevo que hago cuantas cosas
hay que realmente mejorarían la vida de
la gente
si se hicieran y llegarán a ellos
entonces no sólo hay toda una pesadilla
desde que vos imaginas una solución
tecnológica hasta que la resolver es que
el financiamiento que te llega a tiempo
que se devalúa que si ello es una
pesadilla pero peor que eso y no sé cómo
llamarlo es el hecho de que descubriste
la necesidad resolviste técnicamente el
problema y la gente ni se entera en él
sabe que existe y este es uno de los
dramas que tenemos que resolver el
comportamiento del mercado del estado
frente a la necesidad de que las cosas
lleguen a la gente entonces lo que
hicimos es
contamos si en los viejitos nuestra 80
viejita y 10 viejitos más o menos viene
siempre 100 personas y les enseñamos a
auto fabricarse los dispositivos
en una mañana la gente aprende a
fabricarse los dispositivos hicimos
10 talleres de 100 personas genial la
resolución
bien matemática como dijiste hubo 10%
tengo millones de viejo no estoy
llegando entonces el problema es mirar
si lo que el objetivo que vos tener lo
está cumpliendo o no si no lo cumplir
revisa el objetivo si el objetivo es
correcto revisar los procedimientos
entonces ahora estamos volcando esto a
capacitar un pequeño grupo de
funcionarios en cada uno de estos temas
en cada una de las provincias pero digo
no parar hasta que esto no se llegue
él se llamó a los chicos de la escuela
técnica hay hoy 740 escuelas técnicas
que fabrican sillas de ruedas y sillas
posturales que prácticamente no eran
accesibles para la gente
y esas escuelas técnicas
yo he visto cuando un chico entrega una
silla postural y la mamá levanta a su
chiquito del suelo y lo pone en el silla
postural y el pibe dice yo no sé quién
inventó esto pero a mí me cambió la
cabeza a mí me cambió la manera de ser
porque me sabía lo que era una silla
postural ni una persona con discapacidad
y con esto que está un poco lo que yo sé
cómo puedo ayudar a otros y cuando en
una escuela técnica fabricamos el aro
magnético para los hipoacúsicos le
enseñamos a los chicos de la escuela
electrónica en una mañana en una tarde a
fabricar estos equipos
y al día siguiente en la escuela de
sordos una chiquita
cuando se le ponen los audífonos para
probar el aro se le ilumina la cara y le
hace seña de sordo a su mamá y le dice
estoy escuchando música por primera vez
en mi vida lloro la madre lloró
lloramos todos miren las cosas que
realmente pueden pasarse con la
rehabilitación neurológica un chiquito
que nunca nueve años no caminaba
caminaba y tengo una película donde él
patea una pelota y le dice mami qué
lindo que es caminar digo quiero
contarle todo esto civil finalizando un
poco
que selló esta historia esta es la gana
de vivir que tengo porque siento
de los 94 años
tengo toda la vida por delante
y que realmente las cosas que han
cambiado fundamentalmente rojo
los jubilados de antes de los dos años
de jubilados se morían ahora no nos
morimos nada vivimos 20-30 años y
tenemos toda la posibilidad de ver que
en esta etapa de la vida en este nuevo
cuarta etapa de la vida el rol de la
persona que se jubiló cambia totalmente
porque tiene tiempo tiene experiencia
saffo del consumismo se apodera de la
necesidad de estar compitiendo comprando
y entendiendo toda su vida dedicó a
aprender a caminar escribir a trabajar
etcétera
la vida en la medida en que la gente y
digo usted de gente una cultura en la
que pensemos que el rol de la persona
jubilada no es más la misma de antes no
es la de entretenerse 30 años es la de
poder volcar esta experiencia haciendo
las cosas el mercado del estado no las
puede hacer para los otros trabajando en
lo que te gusta y el tiempo que te gusta
y es el otro el que te obliga a esta
situación y yo le digo que la felicidad
que me da a mí a la gente que comparte
conmigo en esta edad la posibilidad de
esta bisagra en la que dejamos de pensar
en el tener y comprar y luchar para
poder volcar esta experiencia y esta
sabiduría y este tiempo a mejorar la
vida del otro es lo que yo le deseo a
todos ustedes que lleguen a mi edad con
la alegría del tener proyecto real un
sentido a su vida de sentir que no están
entreteniéndose el día de la muerte sino
que el contrario yo digo tengo 94 años
tengo toda la vida por delante y no
hablo nunca del último proyecto hablo de
mi próximo proyecto muchas veces
[Aplausos]